so
yeah this is just expensive calorie
counting
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we'll be taking on a
classic weight loss program that sadly
has shown no signs of dying off weight
watchers but first let me tell you about
my sponsor squarespace now if you're not
familiar with squarespace it's an
all-in-one platform to run your business
whether you're looking to build a
website blog online store or use their
marketing tools and analytics you guys
know that between youtube and my blog
and public appearances and parenting two
boys under three
i have no patience for technology
so squarespace is amazing because it
takes care of the seo and site
management for people who are busy
juggling a million things like
businesses and family when everything in
your digital presence works together it
just makes it so much easier for you to
actually focus on your actual business
so you can check out squarespace.com for
a free trial and then when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain and of
course before we get into the video feel
free to pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always please
feel free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you
are new here welcome
welcome to the club
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that bell so that you
never miss out on a video all righty
folks
alrighty then let's jump in now if
you've never heard of weight watchers
well well done bravo but basically it's
one of the og weight loss programs with
a 50-plus year track record of taking
people's money oh and i guess also like
helping people lose weight but it's been
heavily endorsed by major celebs over
the years like oprah jennifer hudson
jessica simpson etc all of whom credit
ww for their weight loss success now
while weight watchers has almost become
a household name by this point the
program recently rebranded itself as ww
and weight watchers reimagined and now
markets itself as a lifestyle rather
than a diet likely as a way to get away
from the dirty d word and the soul focus
on weight and therefore align themselves
with the new more trendy wellness
community and culture but if you're a
regular follower of abby's kitchen
you're surely not fooled by this sneaky
marketing trick you may also remember
that about a year or so ago i reviewed
weight watchers kerbo app aka putting
kids on a diet and if you recall i
wasn't so kind and set off on a lifelong
struggle around food in their body makes
you happy as a parent i think it's time
to re-evaluate your role so since ww is
still to this day such a staple in diet
culture i thought i'd offer you my
thoughts on their updated approach is
this truly promoting a healthy lifestyle
or is this just another form of
restriction so super quickly
ww has long been known for its unique
points system which has evolved over the
years as the program itself has been
updated on weight watchers you don't
have to count calories so freeing but
you just have to count these arbitrary
points oh now according to their website
smart points is our way of making
nutrition science simple and is designed
to help guide you to a healthier pattern
of everyday eating our smarts point
system assigns every food and drink a
points value one simple easy to use
number based on calories saturated fat
sugar and protein foods that are higher
in sugar and or saturated fat are higher
in smarts points values and foods that
are higher in lean protein
are lower in smarts points values okay
when you sign up for ww you basically
get a smart point budget based on your
age gender height and weight so
essentially to lose more weight you
basically need to tighten up that points
budget and eat more zero point foods i
know i know i too have 90s ptsd as well
but if you manage to escape this era of
diet culture according to ww lingo zero
points foods are foods that do not need
to be tracked or measured because
they're considered to be the healthiest
low calorie foods that are essentially
hard to overeat for instance they give
the example that it's a lot harder to
eat six chicken breasts than six cookies
this is a fair point but it's not a
foolproof system we'll chat more about
why i think this system is flawed in a
moment but first i want to describe the
new meal plans so as part of the new
program there are three different meal
plans to choose from and the best plan
for you will be determined by taking a
quiz assessing your habits and your
weight loss goals so to test this out
here's what i did i took the quiz myself
and basically they asked me a ton of
questions about how i feel my goals my
current relationship with food they ask
me questions about when i feel like i've
gotten off track and my self-talk and
what wellness ultimately means to me and
in the grand scheme of most diets out
there i did find it to be a relatively
comprehensive assessment certainly not
what you would glean from a one-on-one
session from a dietitian but definitely
better than the new one i discussed in
detail here now they did ask me about my
weight and height but actually didn't
seem to focus on a numbered weight loss
goal so after the assessment they
evaluate you based on four pillars of
wellness nutrition activity sleep and
mindset and from there
you gotta sign up for a membership which
obviously i didn't want to pay for so
the whole ideal meal plan for me is
apparently hidden behind a paywall and
behind said paywall it shall stay so
anyways that's how it works and then
each food plan claims to promote weight
loss but the plan that's right for you
is the one that allows the most freedom
and flexibility and helps you develop
and sustain healthy habits so there's
the green plan the blue plan and the
purple plan which are basically
distinguished by how many smart points
you get and how zero point foods are
defined confusing yes i know what the
hell are you talking about
in short the green plan gives you the
most smart points but their zero point
foods are limited to only non-starchy
fruits and vegetables the blue plan gets
you moderate smart points and their zero
point foods also includes lean proteins
and the purple plan gets the least
amount of smart points to play with at
their discretion but their zero point
foods also include whole grains so the
way i see this is that the green plant
dieters may have been identified as
needing a lot more guidance and maybe
some more rules to follow in order to
succeed while the purple plan dieters
are maybe less likely to cheat the
system and binge on zero point fruit so
these folks maybe have a better sense of
what feels good in their body and what
keeps them satiated so they can pretty
much eat more like the 80 20 rule with a
little less tracking but with still
having some small daily budgets for
treats and then the green plant folks
maybe need to track an account for
pretty much everything so now that we
understand how ww has evolved and what
it looks like today let's talk about
some of the things that i actually kind
of like about the new ww program
compared to other weight loss diets or
previous iterations first off i do like
the customization of the three-pronged
meal plan system even though it's a bit
confusing so depending on your
relationship with food how much
structure you feel that you need and how
much or how little nutrition knowledge
you already have different systems will
definitely appeal to different people
and i do think that greater
customization in general will always
yield greater chances of success second
unlike with a lot of trendy diets du
jour ww doesn't focus on limiting the
types of food that you can eat so you
don't need to cut out sugar or alcohol
or dairy or gluten or whatever you have
the option to work these foods into your
diet which i do think makes the plan
more accessible to the general
population honestly it's no different
than any other calorie counting or if if
it's your macros type of approach so if
you want to eat the cupcake you just
have to work it into your day third i
think if
a person has a relatively healthy
relationship with food and they're able
to be kind of introspective and collect
data on how certain foods make them feel
while following their plan
that following a general points guide
could potentially teach them some basics
about nutrition so for example specific
to the purple plan i think someone with
a generally good relationship with food
would be able to acknowledge that hey
when i eat low or no points foods like a
few slices of whole grain sourdough with
grilled chicken breast with some salad
for lunch together which would be
cumulatively very low in points on this
plan i feel really satisfied and maybe i
don't need to snack so much afterwards
so if you get that out of the program i
think that's really great now of course
the likelihood of someone with a really
solid relationship with food doing a
diet like ww
is another story but i will get more
into that in a bit number four another
one of the often cited benefits of ww is
the community that the program offers
its members now virtually because of
covet of course members also have access
to live streams pre-recorded messages
workshops and one-on-one coaching and we
do have research to support the idea
that weight loss interventions work best
when not done on their own
lastly and most importantly the program
is supported by research which is more
than most programs online influencers
are peddling or supporting can say so
for example a 2017 clinical trial found
that adults in the wwe program for a
year lost more weight and were able to
maintain their weight loss over two
years better than those who use
self-help materials and then a 2017
review of about 40 studies also found
that those who use ww lost 3 percent
more weight compared to folks who used
other forms of support or canceling now
as for the new updated plans in 2019 a
survey by usa today reported that the
color-coded diet plans actually
decreased levels of hunger by 21 over a
six month period now that all sounds
great i just need to say that of course
like most research on weight loss diets
we really don't know how well people
fare in the long run when they give up
their membership and they stop obsessing
over points and they go out to eat in
the wild drinking your own pee
is truly unpleasant
weight loss intervention research is
notoriously short-lived as is most
weight loss so i do take most weight
loss intervention research with a bit of
a grain of salt but again some research
is better than none so on that note
let's talk about some red flags first
cheating the zero points system whether
you get a lot or little zero point foods
on your plan
there's definitely a risk of abusing the
system being put on any kind of budget
we can develop what i call scarcity
mentality which can lead us to ignore
our body's innate hunger cues as a
result
dieters may end up eating a
ton of zero point foods even if they're
not physically hungry anymore simply you
know because they've got permission to
do just that this can absolutely derail
both weight loss and body intuition for
a few main reasons first of all
depending on the plan that you're on you
can easily rack up an excess in calories
from eating fruit whole grain bread or
chicken breast all day the result could
theoretically be an unbalanced
inadequate diet but also a caloric
surplus depending on what you choose so
when you stop listening to your body it
starts to feel a bit like a game and
people love to find ways to hack games
now i know i just stated that this could
potentially work really well for some
folks with generally good non-emotional
relations with food because it may help
us see that those zero points foods are
the more nutritious satiating foods to
include more often while the smartpoint
foods are like the fun foods that we
want to enjoy in moderation but i'm
gonna go out on a limb here to say
that
most people doing diets like weight
watchers
don't have clear dieting track records
they've likely lost and gained weight
many times in their life and likely
already have assigned a lot of moral
value to the foods on those plans
so
in other words they likely already have
a pretty severe scarcity mentality
that's not going to be healed on any
kind of diet so even though i prefer the
format of something like the purple plan
let's say to the green plan i still do
wonder how often dieters abuse the
flexibility that a plan like this
promises when there's still a budget in
place and weight loss is still the focus
another concern that i have is around
the point system and the unnaturalness
of budgeting food so according to the
rules you're allowed to roll over four
smarts points each day to save them up
for the end of the week this may lead
people to intentionally restrict
themselves to ensure that they have
rollover points to binge on certain days
like a weekend i think this teaches a
really bad habit that can reinforce a
restriction and binging cycle of eating
loads of vegetables and plain chicken
breasts all week long only to drink a
ton of beer and overeat pizza on the
weekend and this is just not healthy
also because you lose your points the
next week if you don't use them it may
encourage dieters to eat past the point
of fullness just to use them up eating
should not be reduced to a math equation
and speaking of a reductionist approach
to food even with a broader range of
zero points foods allowed in the purple
program
i worry that some naturally nourishing
foods are still off the table so as you
progress through the programs and are
allowed things like chicken breasts and
even whole grains with more flexibility
that is still something that needs to be
budgeted for so for example an ounce of
brazil nuts will clock in at nine smarts
points which for a purple plant follower
eats up over half of their points for
the day good thing brazil nuts taste
like ass
no no didn't like it bad taste in my
mouth now i understand why fat rich
foods need to be budgeted for since fat
is calorically dense but i think it
communicates confusing messages to folks
that some foods are good and other foods
are bad it also can result in a really
unbalanced diet if fat rich foods are
specifically omitted or severely limited
in order to save up those points another
issue i have is that it celebrates
quantity not quality so i'll get ww
props that it has come a long way at
trying to perfect this system so as to
encourage people to choose more
nutrient-dense foods so by giving people
more flexibility to choose more
nutrient-dense foods by assigning them
zero-point status and also having sugar
saturated fat and protein levels impact
the assignment of smart points but the
basis of the smart points calculation
is still calories so sugar and saturated
fat slightly raise that number and
protein content can bring it slightly
down but calories are still the driving
force here and with enough scheming
again
it's not hard to stack your day with
less nutritious foods so for example
an ultra processed fat-free hot dog has
one point where a tablespoon of peanut
butter and some apple slices has three
if you're trying to save your points for
a weekend cheat day
you could do that by theoretically
eating a whole pack of these wieners
that's what she said without the bun and
i'm not sure that's what we really want
to encourage people to do so if you
haven't succeeded with counting calories
or counting macros for weight loss i
don't think that this is much different
it's basically the same thing but with a
better pr team plus oprah oh and it's
not free either and that brings me to
the cost now depending on your plan
you're looking at anywhere between 24.99
and 56.29 a month so for a year that
works out to almost 300 to almost 700 a
year
not even including the sign up fee for a
lot of people this is just out of reach
and it doesn't even include the food
costs now unlike learning other gentle
nutrition 101 strategies that i
discussed in my video right here there's
a huge concern that when you stop paying
for the app and the accountability
system and the point system guides you
might not have the nutrition knowledge
or skills to really transform this into
a lifestyle it's like always using a
calculator or spell check so that you
never need to learn how to do math or
write that could be an expensive
lifestyle and lastly you're paying for
unqualified coaching so according to
linkedin wwe does include some
registered dietitians on staff but the
accountability coaches available for the
premium versions of the program
don't seem to have any nutrition or
health qualifications i did some
sleuthing looking at 10 wwe coaches on
linkedin
and only one was a dietitian and she
specialized in diabetes specific cases
the other nine had backgrounds in either
sales communication or product
development obviously is it that obvious
i'm sorry now of course this is not an
official survey of the staff at ww but
from the information that i can find
publicly it doesn't seem like ww
requires their coaches to have any
official nutrition or health background
so if you're looking for a personalized
nutrition program and somebody to hold
you accountable with credentials to do
so properly i would think your money
would be much better spent investing in
an actual rd so to summarize i do think
that the new ww programs seem to offer
greater flexibility and options than
previous versions while maintaining the
kind of community and the accountability
aspects that it's been celebrated for in
the past but unless you're willing to
pay for the structure that they built
for life it may not set you up to make
healthy eating a lifestyle and maybe
that's a really good business move on
their part like why teach a man or a
woman to fish when it'll mean that they
no longer pay you to fish for them so in
conclusion while some research suggests
that wwe dieters do achieve success we
really don't know how dieters fare long
term or when they stop paying for the
service but if the data we have on
weight loss diets in general is any
indication most people will probably
gain the weight back not all but most
and of course calorie counting or pseudo
calorie counting like this
can absolutely work for some folks but i
do worry about the scarcity mentality of
a program like this so if you're looking
for more sustainable weight loss tips
that don't cost you anything to learn
definitely check out my video right here
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today thank you again to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up
leave me a comment below on other diets
that you want to see me review subscribe
to the channel and i will see you next
time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]